Everything really kind of depends on the
budget.
If Congress passes adequate
appropriations for the war,
uh,
for the new fiscal year beginning in
October,
regardless of how angry they are,
regardless of how much verbiage shows up
and the congressional record or in the
statute,
uh,
and Petraeus has given a reasonably free
hand for another year,
I think the chance of exiting with some
degree of stability might be fairly
good.
If that doesn't happen,
uh,
if the forces in the field are crippled
by appropriations cuts,
um,
that could be very bad from the point of
view of either being able to prevail
over a okayed in Iraq or,
uh,
um,
being able to leave any kind of a stable
situation behind.